hi my name is jason graziani for
valuetainment
and today i wanted to ask you a question
who do you think the two most powerful
groups of people are in the united
states of america
i'll give you a second to think about it
who do you think the two most powerful
groups of people are
in the united states of america i would
submit to you
that it's politicians and business
executives
those who run our government and those
who run our private sector
now the point that i want to make with
this is that a lot of times people are a
part of a company
and they complain about where the
company's going or the future or the
direction that the leadership is taking
it in
and then there's people that are part of
the united states of america namely
you and i and many other people and we
have opinions that go one way or the
other
and we judge our leadership and say we
don't like the direction that the
country is going in
but what i want to submit to you today
is how can we blame either one
of these groups when the incentives that
we impose on them
are both for the short term let me
explain
if you're a politician how often are you
judged
or how often are you measured this
happens every two to four years with an
election cycle
and who judges you the voters so if you
are in a position of leadership and you
want to institute change for the long
term
but you're being judged in the short
term how can you rightfully
operate with the long term in mind when
you're constantly evaluated
every two to four years let's change
gears to the private sector
here you have the corporate executives
the big business
and we want our companies and we want
our corporations to be thinking about
the long-term well-being
for their clients for the country for
their investors
however how often are these executives
measured and who measures them every
quarter they have to bring out their
earnings
and they have to report to their
shareholders who are deciding whether
they want to keep their investments with
these companies or not
and so where we elect and we're where we
put these ceos and
these cfos in place to run a company for
the long term
we have no incentives for the long term
because these are only done on a
quarterly and an annual basis
and so to summarize if you're out there
and you're wondering
hey that's a good point we want to build
for the long term both as a society and
a civilization
as well as our individual households
what can you do as an individual
to institute change one your purchasing
power
in the private sector as well as your
voting power
in the public sector you could respond
with what you spend your money on and
who you vote for
but in the bigger scale i would make
sure that you're making decisions
on a daily basis whether it affects your
church or your family
or whether it affects your business or
the community around you
make decisions for the long term and i
don't think you'll be disappointed
so as a society we need to decide what's
most important
is it more important to give our leaders
more time
both on the government side and the
private sector side in order to
institute change
and to properly lead for the long term
or
is it better to constantly manage and
constantly evaluate in the short term
causing them to make a lot of short term
decisions i'm interested to hear your
feedback
post your comments below and make sure
you subscribe to valuetainment
this is jason graziani for my message of
the week signing off
have a great day